if you are fine with your own money
being used to advance a climate agenda
or a racial Equity agenda if you are
fine with using your dollars to tell
Apple that they have to adopt a racial
Equity hiring system that they don't
want to adopt or that that oil companies
should produce less oil even if that
means higher prices at the pump
there's no problem with this because
that's what a good number of people
would want to do with their own money
turns out though most Americans don't
want to advance that agenda with their
own money their hard-earned life savings
their 401K accounts their retirement
accounts their brokerage accounts they
don't want that well it turns out the
rude surprises guess what your money is
being used to advance those agendas
anyway so you think you go to The Ballot
Box and vote every November that's what
you said people are concerned about
guess what I got news for you you're
already voting every day without your
knowledge with your own hard-earned
dollars to do it